it was always super tough uh but but  definitely of course if i have a chance  and i feel that i can get in shape then  uh then then it's then it's fine but  look at this you were right one e4 on  the board and duda goes e for e6  okay and queen h5 wow okay  this come on  fancy business but what is this did he  expect e5 because we know that again c5  he has been playing a lot of queen h5s  but what is this  i think he's enjoying himself that  that's all i'm gonna say i think hikaru  thinks right come on it's the last game  potentially of the tour you know let's  have some fun i'm gonna i'm just gonna  wheel it out you know i've got he's got  obviously a major fan club i'm gonna i'm  gonna get them something to talk about  and i'm gonna play queen h5 what the  hell um  uh but  it's maybe not to be tried at home i  remember peter very funny story when i  was teaching in schools chess and i was  teaching beginners